j'ai un gros problème de sécurité lié à
mon quantique toc j'ai contacté tik tok
le problème n'est toujours pas résolu je
vais vous en parler parce que ça peut
vous aussi vous arrivez est posée gros
problèmes de sécurité et d'ailleurs j'ai
une réponse de tik tok et croyez moi
elle est très surprenante
alors je repose les faits je vous
explique si vous me suivez vous savez
qu'à la chaîne youtube là vous la
regardez mais j'ai également être
content tweets sur lequel je fais des
lives ans ça fait un petit moment que je
n'ai pas fait les chemins et des lives
et j'ai fait un live ya presque un an
pour présenter les rpac d'apple si vous
savez pas ce que sont les attaques
d'apple avait acheté un petit coup
d'oeil sur ma chaîne youtube ou ailleurs
vous trouverez rapidement et quand j'ai
configuré mon airtag en direct qu'est ce
qui s'est passé mon numéro de téléphone
s'afficher sur mon téléphone et oui ça
forcément ça lire par exemple
normalement tout le monde n'est pas
censé le voir mais comme je défends
direct hop le temps que j'enlève il y
avait des captures d'écran et mon
téléphone a commencé à sonner une fois
live terminé j'appelle bouygues telecom
et chardy il faut me changer de numéro
de téléphone ils disent bien sûr on y va
et numéro de téléphone d'échangés
extrêmement rapidement sauf que il a
fallu donner mon nouveau numéro à tous
mes contacts donc je les fais au fur et
à mesure et bien évidemment le changé
sur mes comptes youtube j'ai fait très
rapidement et je les fait petit à petit
pour d'autres comptes et j'ai pas pensé
à contacter tik tok tout de suite je me
suis rendu compte que sur tik tok il ya
très peu de temps et bien mon ancien
numéro de téléphone était toujours
attaché à mon compte et qu'on nous vole
n'était pas donc cherché une solution
directement dans l'application pour
pouvoir changer mon numéro de téléphone
mais ce n'est pas possible j'ai donc
contacté match adel manager artik toc ou
camille pour lui dire voilà mon ancien
vol hammonds nouveau numéro de téléphone
est ce que tu peux changer sa star
message qu'ils étaient il ya pas
longtemps j'ai changé de numéro de
téléphone à quelques mois et il est
maintenant impossible de le modifier
dans le back office de tik tok lorsque
je me suis pris mon ancien numéro
téléphone tik tok de vérifier sa
validité mais je n'en dispose plus j'ai
peur que quelqu'un qui ait récupéré mon
numéro via son opérateur qui
souhaiteraient se connecter à mon kotick
toc peut se faire sans difficulté eh
bien oui parce qu'en fait c'est un
procès ce cachet tik tok et qui est un
peu relou lorsque vous venez dans vos
paramètres tik tok directement
paramètres et confidentialité vous allez
dans le conte et la voyez c'est mon
ancien numéro de téléphone et j'ai mon
email et lorsque je vais modifier je
clique là ils doivent d'abord m'envoyer
un sms directement au numéro là sauf que
le numéro je lis plus donc ça sert à
rien la personne qui reçoit le sms est
la nouvelle personne qui a récupéré mon
ancien numéro de téléphone et c'est plus
moi donc quelqu'un et je ne sais pas qui
reçoit un sms de tik tok en disant
connecte toi qu en tic toc donc ça déjà
gros gros gros gros problème c'est ce
que font les opérateurs et c'est ce qu'a
fait bouygues telecom ici avec moi au
lieu de donner un nouveau numéro de
téléphone ils ont recyclé un ancien
numéro de téléphone dont quelques uns
étaient séparés quelques mois auparavant
laisse un laps de temps pour les
personnes étant de contacter tous ses
contacts via maintien voilà mon nouveau
numéro téléphone il faut changer il faut
croire que tu ne le fais pas parce que
moi j'ai reçu des messages whatsapp j'ai
reçu des propos j'ai reçu plein de
choses d'ailleurs je vous invite à venir
vous inscrire sur blocs telle blocs
texte un service du gouvernement et qui
va venir mettre votre téléphone sur une
liste où vous n'aurez pas le droit des
démarches et en principe il m'est donc
strictement impossible de changer mon
numéro de téléphone par moi même ce à
quoi calmer il me répond nous disons
tiens regarde il existe aujourd'hui un
service spécifique qui s'occupe de ça
chez tik tok voilà ce qu'ils peuvent
faire ils peuvent donc changer mon
numéro de téléphone il ya aucun problème
je contacte donc ce service ont des
changes donc avec ce service par mail et
une demande de montrer patte blanche et
ce qui est super ce qui est extrêmement
rassurant une demande dont l'identifiant
la date à laquelle je me suis inscrit
l'endroit d'où je me suis connectée est
assez peu de temps sur quel appareil
monde ancien numéro de téléphone ok
jusque là tout va bien je leur réponds
c'est extrêmement rassurant il demande
une vérification supplémentaire ce qui
me va bien et à la famille ok on est
d'accord que les nouveaux nouveau numéro
de téléphone et ça c'est le deuxième
problème le numéro de téléphone que je
veux récupérer est détenu par un autre
compte je ne peux donc pas le récupérer
et on demande de renvoyer un nouveau
numéro de téléphone genre explique que
je sais que le numéro de téléphone est
bien à moi qu'il est lié à un autre
compte mec l'autre compte n'a plus accès
à ce numéro de téléphone on ne pourra
rien faire de ce compte et je leur dis
ok d'état celle de ce conte est rattaché
le à mon compte puisque je vous le mets
et je leur envoyais une capture d'écran
aujourd'hui regardez c'est moi qui ait
accès à ce numéro de téléphone j'ai pas
de réponse quelques jours après je leur
envoie une petite mise à jour est ce que
vous avez reçu mon email d'avant et me
disent comme je voulais dit ce numéro de
téléphone appartient déjà à quelqu'un on
ne peut pas vous la tribu et il n'est
pas possible donnez nous un nouveau
numéro de téléphone et je leur explique
à nouveau je redis il ya un problème de
sécurité parce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai accès
au compte de quelqu'un je ne devrais pas
avoir accès à ce compte là je demande
donc de détacher le numéro de téléphone
de l'autre compte ou alors par moi même
je vais devoir supprimer le compte de
quelqu'un d'autre pour pouvoir au bout
de 30 jours je crois récupérer le numéro
de téléphone et c'est là que leur
réponse m'a quand même un peu mis sur le
cul à savoir un seul numéro de téléphone
peut être lié un compte ce qui me
suggère de faire c'est de supprimer le
compte lié à nouveau numéro de téléphone
je vais donc utiliser le compte de
quelqu'un auquel j'aurais même pas dû
avoir accès et en disant ok eh bien je
vais supprimer ce compte là pour pouvoir
au bout de 30 jours récupérer le numéro
de téléphone et ils voulaient marquer en
bout de 30 jours il sera totalement
désactivé supprimer de façon permanente
et à ce moment là je pourrai récupérer
le numéro de téléphone et le mettre sur
mon nouveau compte c'est dingue ce qu'on
dit on me dit il ya une erreur la
personne ce qu'elle a fait c'est qu'elle
n'a pas activé la double identification
et ça c'est vraiment que je vous
recommande plus plus plus plus plus à
faire dès maintenant sur votre compte il
toque regardez vous allez y si vous
allez dans les paramètres et
confidentialité vous allez dans sécurité
et là vous venez activer la vérification
en deux étapes c'est extrêmement
important alors moi j'ai deux façons
pour me connecter et j'ai bien sûr
supprimer la connexion avec mon ancien
numéro de téléphone pour que quelqu'un
ne puisse pas venir se connecter comme
ça je vais donc soit par mail soit par
mot de passe donc lorsque je me
connectais je fais avec mon mail ils
vont m'envoyer un mail pour vérifier
vouloir ça sera directement par mon mot
de passe c'est extrêmement important
parce que si vous le faites pas et que
vous changer de numéro de téléphone est
bien la personne qui a récupéré votre
ancien numéro de téléphone pourra se
connecter à votre compte de la même
manière que je les fais avec la personne
là et sans même le vouloir alors
regardez je vous montre pour me
connecter à votre compte ça me paraît
dingue je vais dans les paramètres de
confidentialité je vais tout en bas je
vais dans changer de compte je fais
ajouter un compte avec le numéro de
téléphone je clique sur envoyer un code
il m'envoie un code la up il est là il
est validé et voilà j'ai accès au compte
de la personne alors c'est un tout petit
content il ya un abonnement voyage accès
à une vidéo privée avec quelqu'un qui
danse il pourrait y avoir une importe
quoi sur ce compte mais le truc qui me
paraît dingue là dedans c'est de se dire
que j'écris à tik tok et ils sont pas en
capacité de nous trouver une solution
qui va venir d'une protéger ce compte là
qui est un compte privé c'est criant aux
comptes privés et qu'on me demande moi
alors je n'ai pas le droit de le faire
devenir supprimé le compte d'un
utilisateur tiers parce que j'ai
récupéré le numéro de téléphone et parce
que aujourd'hui ne sont pas en mesure de
le faire donc là il ya un très gros
problème de sécurité tik tok il faut
venir corriger ça il faut venir proposer
d'autres solutions d'autres possibilités
que uniquement de me dire ok tu as
récupéré le numéro de téléphone que je
propose c'est de venir toi effacé parce
que nous on peut rien faire pour toi
donc ça c'est quand même vraiment
problématique imaginez que quelqu'un ait
pu se connecter à mon compte tik tok
grâce à mon ancien numéro de téléphone
et que je n'ai pas à modifier de la
deuxième faille que je m'en sois pas
rendu compte qu est ce qui se serait
passé eh bien il serait juste passé que
quelqu'un aurait pu supprimer mon compte
je ne sais pas forcément rendu compte et
puis le supprimer toutes les vidéos et
je veux dire ce compte là c'est pas
comme si j'avais pas bosser pour la bord
alors c'est sûr que par rapport à
d'autres comptes qui ont un million des
centaines de milliers d'abonnés j'ai
presque cent mille abonnés déjà quand
même plutôt pas mal ça représente
beaucoup de travail et rien que pour ça
pour moi il ya un gros problème de
sécurité voilà donc ça il faut le
modifier tik tok c'est extrêmement
important et vous pensez à activer la
deuxième phase très important si tu
sandras pour les soins de nouveaux
tricks 1
[Musique]